mientras los líderes de las economías
más grandes del mundo están reunidos en
el castillo del mal en las calles de la
ciudad más cercanas cientos de
manifestantes ponen en duda el impacto
del g7 para proteger el medio ambiente
tengo 17 años hay gente sentada ahí que
me cuadruplica la edad discutiendo mi
futuro sin preguntar a ningún joven lo
que queremos ni una sola vez y no
debería ser así
que tan justo es que hayan gastado 166
millones de euros en esos dos días y que
tan justo es que las decisiones que se
están tomando hoy sean tan
significativas sobre todo para el sur
global sobre todo para mi futuro como
joven y hoy protesto aquí por la
justicia climática y para que se tomen
las decisiones correctas para que yo
tenga un futuro y que nuestra tierra no
se dañe por completo del lado de las ong
el discurso es similar los activistas de
la organización oxfam estaban presentes
con sus ya famosos disfraces de los
líderes para interpelar los directamente
y pedirles de respetar al acuerdo de
parís
esperamos una señal clara de que van a
realizar claras mejoras en lo que
respecta a la del clima
esperamos que apliquen un plan de acción
contra el hambre y la pobreza
hemos escuchado demasiadas veces
palabras bonitas en lugar de acciones
concretas el g7 debe comprometerse a
actuar de verdad ahora
el sábado las protestas en alemania se
desarrollaron con tranquilidad cerca de
4000 personas respondieron al llamado de
unas 15 ong y marcharon en múnich este
año el dispositivo de seguridad es muy
importante más de 18 mil policías están
desplegados para evitar a toda costa
reproducir los enfrentamientos durante
la cumbre del g20 en hamburgo en 2017